[Music]
more and more these days we're hearing
how important microbiome is right good
gut flora healthy gut bacteria so to
speak and then you've got probiotics
right good bacteria and prebiotics which
are essentially the nutrients for the
probiotics I have heard and I have read
many studies linking healthy gut flora
to everything from the inhibition of
Alzheimer's to it being linked to autism
and children to a healthy fast
metabolism and on and on and on and I
remember years ago when I wrote my book
mastering your metabolism by the time we
died trying to remember the exact number
but I believe that like only one out of
every 10 cells in our body is even human
anymore like we have so much bacteria in
our system and this should be a good
thing right but because we're over
prescribed antibiotics and because so
much of the animal products we consume
that are non-organic the animals have
been fed antibiotics because they're in
horrendous feedlot conditions that make
them sick and unhealthy plus the
antibiotics and they're extra mint runs
off into our water supply so essentially
we are being inundated with antibiotics
from all different directions on a
consistent basis and our diets are not
well-rounded enough that we're
replenishing so yet another reason we're
oh I don't do dairy we can't make these
unilateral statements I do dairy I do it
if I'm following a calorie allowance and
I'm having an equally balanced
macronutrient ratio how many calories of
animal protein am I getting a day at the
most six hundred so the dairy I choose
is organic and it's fermented and I
that's also very rich in soluble and
insoluble fiber so I'm getting my
enzymes I'm getting my probiotics and
I'm getting the prebiotics to help keep
the probiotics flourishing
[Music]